[Music]
I know what I was thinking go
[Music]
so I'm a big fan of Casey Neistat and
I've been following his vlog since 2015
when it started and at that time in my
life I thought it was too late to pursue
any kind of creative career but after
watching him and listening to his story
I realized that it wasn't too late I
spent all my time online learning how to
make videos and eventually led me here
to New York City I'm really curious but
a day-in-the-life the Casey nice that
looks like so I'm gonna try to run like
Casey everyday for the next five days
before I can run like Casey I need to
figure out how far he actually runs
about ten miles per day we watched over
200 of the original vlogs and he
mentions running in 37 of them and out
of those 37 he ran 369 Mills and if you
divide that up it's about 10 miles per
day I'll take the first couple steps on
day one here I don't need
[Music]
calves are really starting to tighten up
yeah this is tough this is really all
right seven miles in kind of reaching
that limit three more just past eight
mile mark everything everybody's telling
me to stop two more to go ten miles done
oh my god I'm sorry I can already feel
my legs starting to like you we'll see
how I feel in the morning so far so good
all right so it's day 2 and I am already
so impressed with Casey I don't know how
he does this every single day all right
one mile done so it feels rough so far
[Applause]
[Music]
Casey definitely runs down this pier
[Applause]
[Music]
do that that's a good spot to
[Music]
I don't know you do this everyday put
your phone down run come back I mean
that really add some distance after a
while I'm wasting a lot of time filming
stuff I have to run the next five miles
in under an hour to get back to working
time for a shoot so I gotta just keep
going I'll check back in at the end
another 10 miles done the last two are a
real real struggle okay on to date three
alright to be totally honest this part
gets boring I'm running I'm tired I'm
store alright we get it and so let's
just jump ahead to day four but the end
of day four and we'll go from there
that was the worst run yet I mean
everything is just soaked so if you're a
fan of the old vlogs you know that case
you had run in the city quite a bit but
he'd also run somewhere else so if I'm
gonna run like Casey I got a really good
find
[Music]
alright a few hours later I am out of
the city in New London Connecticut for
my final day of running let's do it
[Music]
all right Beach was super fun I'm gonna
head to the town now
[Music]
I'm so close to finishing oh yeah but
weeks late really catch enough to me
today almost there
I feel a lot slower running here because
you can see so far in this idiom is like
flying past people and buildings it
feels so quick I'm not very fast I guess
oh my god I did that's stupid
don't ever do this again ten miles every
day for five days just done I need
something to eat it oh it's done I her
hand ten miles a day for five days I am
exhausted my whole body is so somewhere
and I respect the guy even more to run
ten miles and film it and vlog your life
I know how he does it all I really don't
I gotta work harder
[Music]
[Music]